Y
BOMBARDED BY THIS RUSSIAN
INVASION, RICHARD.
>> SCOTT MCLAIN, IN KYIV.
THANK YOU >> GERMANY'S
WRENCHING AWAY.
IT IS DOING SO USING NATURAL
GAS AND HYDROGEN.
PLANS WERE ANNOUNCED TO TEAM UP
WITH NORWAY TO BUILD POWER
PLANTS IN GERMANY.
FUELED BY NATURAL GAS, IT IS
BEING PUMPED THROUGH A NEW
PIPELINE.
ALSO, THE FIVE FLOATING
LIQUEFIED NATURAL GAS TERMINALS
IN GERMANY NOW COMING ONLINE.
THE FIRST ONE RECEIVED ITS
FIRST SHIPMENT OF GAS ON
TUESDAY.
THE SECOND WILL OPEN SOONER.
BEHIND SOME OF THESE OPERATIONS
IS AL AND G, THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE IS ERIK, HE JOINS ME
FROM OSLO.
SO, I LOOKED AT THIS IN SOME
DETAIL.
IT IS COMPLICATED.
VERY MUCH SO.
BETWEEN GETTING THE STUFF OUT
OF THE GROUND, CONVERTING IT
INTO GAS, PUTTING IT ON A BOAT,
TAKING IT ACROSS THE OCEAN, AND
THEN YOU CONVERT.
YOU HAVE THESE OF STORE
TERMINALS.
HOW DO THEY ACTUALLY INCREASE
OR REDUCE THE RELIANCE ON
RUSSIA?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
SO, WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT THE
TERMINALS THAT WE PROVIDE ARE
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE AL AND
GE VALUE TEAMS.
AT THE PRODUCTION SITE, THE
NATURAL GAS IS COOL DOWN AND
COMPRESSED INTO LIQUEFIED L AND
G.
IT IS THEN TRANSPORTED ON SHIPS
ACROSS THE OCEAN.
AND ON THE INPUTS SIDE, THE
VESSELS CONNECT TO OUR FLOATING
TERMINALS, PUMP THE LNG INTO
THE STORAGE TANKS.
AND THEN WE HEAT IT BACK INTO
NATURAL GAS AND FEED IT INTO
THE SYSTEM IN GERMANY.
IT IS USED FOR HEATING HOMES
AND POWERING INDUSTRY.
IT IS THIS FLOATING TERMINAL
THAT THEN HAS BEEN BOOKED LIKE
IN EUROPE IN PARTICULAR
GERMANY.
WHAT THEY DO IS REALLY PROVIDE
ACCESS TO THE LNG MARKETS.
>> HOW MUCH WILL THIS ALLOW THE
INCREASE OF L AND G THROUGH
THESE TERMINALS?
OVER THE LAST YEAR, I HAVE SEEN
MAPS AND GRAPHS THAT REALLY
SHOW IT'S A SHORTAGE OF THESE
TERMINALS THAT'S PREVENTED MORE
LNG COMING FROM THE UNITED
STATES.
>> THAT IS RIGHT, WE WERE QUITE
PROUD WHEN THE GERMAN
CHANCELLOR OLAF SCHOLZ AND HIS
NEW YEAR SPEECH THE GERMAN
PEOPLE MENTIONED ARE LNG
TERMINAL.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY IMPRESSED
WITH THE GOVERNMENT IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME WHO HAVE
INITIATED AT LEAST EIGHT
DIFFERENT TERMINAL PROJECTS.
TWO OF THEM LAND BASE, SIX
FLOATING TERMINALS.
TOGETHER, WITH OUR PARTNERS,
OUR WEMT, TO RE-GAS, TOTAL AND
UNIPER, WE WILL DELIVER THE
THREE FIRST L AND JAY TERMINALS
INTO GERMANY.
THE FIRST ONE WAS OPENED IN
JUST BEFORE CHRISTMAS.
THE TWO NEXT ONES WOULD BE
OPENED IN A MATTER OF WEEKS IN
BROOKLYN AND LEVINE.
COMBINED, THEY WILL HAVE A
CAPACITY OF 20 BILLION CUBIC
METERS.
THAT IS APPROXIMATELY A THIRD
OF WHAT GERMANY IMPORTED FROM
RUSSIA IN 2021.
I JUST WANT TO JUMP IN IF I
MAY.
THE RELATED ISSUE OF COURSE,
THIS VAST EXPENDITURE ON THESE
TERMINALS WHEN --
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE REDUCTION
TAKES PLACE AND GERMANY IS NO
LONGER SO RELIANT.
ARE THESE TERMINALS ABLE TO
EXIST HUNGRY AND OTHER PLACES
WHERE THERE WILL BE OUR
ALLIANCE FOR LONGER?
>> THAT IS WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
FLOATING TERMINALS WHICH ARE
ESSENTIALLY SHIPS TO BE
FANTASTIC ASSETS.
FOR SEVERAL REASONS, FIRST OF
ALL, THEY CAN BE DEPORTED
QUICKLY.
THE FIRST ONE WE DELIVERED
WITHIN TEN MONTHS TOGETHER WITH
OUR PARTNERS.
THEY ARE ALSO VERY FLEXIBLE.
SO, THEY CAN BASICALLY BE
REMOVED WHEN YOU DON'T NEED
THEM ANYMORE.
THEY CAN BE RELOCATED TO
ANOTHER PLACE.
OR THEY CAN BE REPLACED.
THEY ARE ALSO COST-EFFECTIVE.
WE ESTIMATE THERE ARE 40 OR 50%
LOWER COST AND LAMBAST
TERMINALS.
ABSOLUTELY, THEY HAVE A GREAT
FLEXIBILITY AND PROVIDE ACCESS.
>> IS THERE AN OBSOLESCENCE
BUILT INTO THIS, BEARING IN
MIND WE ARE REDUCING FOSSIL
FUELS.
THEREFORE --
DO YOU SEE THAT THERE WILL
ALWAYS BE A NEED FOR TERMINALS?
>> WELL, IN EUROPE, DEFINITELY
THE USE OF NATURAL GAS WILL BE
REDUCED.
THE PEAK HERE WAS PROBABLY LAST
YEAR.
THE PIPELINE GAS WILL SEE THE
BIGGEST REDUCTION.
SO, ACTUALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE LIQUID NATURAL GAS YEAR, IT
WILL INCREASE.
LNG WILL CREASE OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS.
WHILE NATURAL GAS WILL COME
DOWN, THE LNG SHARED WILL STILL
BE VERY IMPORTANT.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE THE
PRODUCTION THROUGH THE
PIPELINES WILL BE REDUCED.
AND THEN WE WILL BE REPLACING
THE RUSSIAN GAS.
>> FASCINATING.
THIS IS THE REAL SOLUTION IN A
SENSE.
FOR THE LAST YEAR, WE HEARD
CONSTANTLY ABOUT THE INABILITY
TO PROVIDE MORE L AND G TO TAKE
UP THE RUSSIAN SLACK.
THIS SEEMS TO BE AT LEAST A
SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THAT ANSWER.
A GREAT EXAMPLE, LITHUANIA BACK
IN 2012 DECIDED THEY COULD NO
LONGER BE RELIANT ON RUSSIAN
GAS.
THEY LAUNCHED A TENDER.
SINCE 2014, OUR VESSEL WHICH
WAS NAMES INDEPENDENTS WAS
OPERATIONAL SINCE 2014.
THERE ARE PEOPLE CHEERING AND
WAVING FLAGS AND MARCHING BANDS
ET CETERA.
WHEN IT ARRIVED, IT WAS ALMOST
CELEBRATED LIKE AN INDEPENDENCE
DAY.
TODAY, LITHUANIA IS COMPLETELY
ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
AND ALSO PROVIDING GAS TO
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES, SUCH AS
POLAND AND LATVIA.
>> I NEED TO COME UP AND SEE